former Google insider Tristan Harris as
urgent action is needed to address the
dark side of Technology Harris was among
the first in Silicon Valley to share his
concerns about people's dependence on
technology when he spoke with 60 minutes
like in 2017 now the former Google
design ethicist is pushing for a new
agenda for tech companies to stop what
he calls the downgrading of humans
Harris is the co-founder of the Center
for Humane Technology good morning and
welcome things the reason I think
there's a connection is it means stay
away from your devices and then you
won't be spoiled but people can't stay
away from their devices but tell me what
downgrading of humans means well so the
the point is this this is an issue
that's bigger than the screen time it's
not about addiction you know people are
seeing these things is disconnected
outrageous ocation of our politics teen
addiction to mental health issues social
isolation but these are all connected
because they're all part of the business
model of extracting human attention the
race to the bottom of the brainstem and
that systematically leads to this
connected system of downgrading humans
well we're upgrading the machines were
downgrading humans downgrading our
attention spans downgrading our mental
health downgrading our democracy and our
civility because the business model says
that outrage works better because
outrage works on that part of the brain
where you release all the norms and
social filters and all that yeah they're
really your animal brain exactly so
first we go and your animal brain you
get your attention but then to go deeper
we have to get hundreds and millions of
people addicted to getting attention
from other people so this is how you get
the teen issues with mental health where
you have you know teenage girls who are
addicted to getting attention from other
people the number of likes they have and
it's I think two and a half times
self-harm and depression issues for teen
girls we tend to flip there's a local
person don't the companies know they're
doing that the tech companies know
they're doing that trust on I think that
they don't like to admit that the
business model of our stock prices
directly anchored to how many minutes
from your mind that I can get from you
it's a direct coupling we need to
decouple this thing this is like moving
from you know the fossil fuels era where
stock prices are directly connected to
how much we're polluting to you know
something that's more regenerative and
so we need to move to regenerative
attention economy that doesn't downgrade
humans we heard the Facebook CEO Mark
Zuckerberg said that Facebook will
become a privacy so
best social network does that make sense
to you how do you interpret that well
the issue is that they're trying to
avoid liability I'm sure there's many
things that there there are good reasons
for doing what they're doing but when
they move all this you know the Russian
hacking the pedophilia stuff all this
this stuff that's going on in these
different groups when suddenly they're
inside of private groups it's not their
responsibility and so wow I thought of
it like that so once it's encrypted they
don't have to be responsible for telling
you know the FBI or whatever we knew
this was happening because they can't
know yeah so one of the challenges that
moves this really important activity
into the dark where it can't be tracked
and that's one of the negative issues
doesn't that make it worse it can
although everything is complicated and
so it's you know they have good reasons
for doing what they're doing but it
that's the cynical view can I go back to
regenerative because that sounds hopeful
and this can get very depressing very
yeah a lot of the things that companies
do it's like taking the labels off a
liquor bottle yeah it's not gonna stop
you from drinking because you know the
bottle is still there so what is
actually regenerative that might you
know offer some light the point is that
they could be competing and erased the
top to help us find common ground I'm
heating and erase to the top to help
people who feel isolated find connection
but they have to move from the business
model right now all the dating apps for
example they want to keep you swiping
for as long as possible imagine they're
competing to make it easier to spend
time with people and meet people and
that's what we can actually make that
change happen especially Apple by the
way is in the best position to change
that because their business model is not
capturing attention but give us a
specific that might you know technology
that might make us feel more alive
rather than then killing us think of
your phone like a like in the GPS your
GPS isn't meant to suck you into the GPS
the GPS is meant to get you out back
into the world to imagine a future a
humane world where technologies like a
GPS and it's just getting us back into
the places where we you know humans are
really good at empathy we're really good
at connection we have all these
evolutionary instincts that work for us
we just need to have technology support
that do you think Silicon Valley wishes
you would stop talking I think there's a
combination of frustration but also
respect because this is all just laying
up facts and everybody knows that
everything I've said is true this is
about and I'm doing this not because I
want attention or selling a book or
anything like that but because it's an
urgent existential issue we don't tackle
these issues we're
a destroyer commonground we can't agree
on facts if we can't agree on facts you
can't do anything whether it's
inequality climate change we have to
have a shared agenda but we want to do
totally agree with you then the loss of
civility yes downgrading as you say of
humans that ultimately affects our
democracy that's really to get good
things done exactly always the words of
the race to the bottom of the brainstem
is sort of chilling Tristana yeah let's
turn it into a race to the top so we're
listening to you thank you thank you
having me